from Welsh girl from an unknown flight
deck of an island to supermodel darling
hi I'm Michael you look like you're in
hell I'm sorry conceded your eyes down a
camera well they only drag you away in
the end a defining cultural icon of our
times as ageless art director of
American Vogue
she is fashions version of a literary
giant I've got to admit it I've had some
butterflies about all of this oh you
mean about fashion generally well that's
a separate issue now I'm talking about
meeting Grace Coddington because it's
like meeting any great leader in their
field
heyget [ __ ] when I make one of those
great no I'm not that when I made a
great Taliban commander I get a little
bit nervous or a little star general
yeah I would be it's the same you know I
mean you are Grace Coddington I mean how
do you carry that forget by gonna
question yeah well tell me about fashion
all right I'm a stranger in a strange
land I've been here a week I think I
know less than when I arrived
probably a music does any of this thing
have any meaning I mean I think we're
all more lost than we have before
we're at a very strange moment in
fashion especially never been under such
assault if I may use that word before
this company I think I will show off on
it it is and it doesn't it and you know
one has to ask the question I can't
remember it being in such a kind of
strange place and it's a cultural thing
it's not just the fashion thing so you
know all this is happening because of
all the different things that are
happening in the world you know you cut
to wear clothes at a extreme and very
fashion II doesn't feel right now
because it's not that moment in
political situation or the cultural
situation obviously it affects fashion
it does because that is not like a
little island it well this is precisely
one of burning questions I've had is
about that interface between history or
all culture and fashion right now we
live in a relatively dark political life
yeah where Paris can blow up at any
moment
Brussels can blow up at any moment
battering can offer us an escape or it
can offer us an expression of that merit
or it should offer all those things one
I reflect yeah yeah and it does at least
I only and what we're seeing now is
exactly that it it's a reflection of all
the insecurities and the darkness and
all those different things that you
mentioned you really think it is yeah
yeah I do I just be a little pet series
as a outsider how you gather even he's
not really a fashion person you know
start to love the way she looked at me
when she said that oh my god
[Music]
[Music]